Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
En 2013, un restaurant londonien a servi
un plat très spécial : le premier hamburger
à base de viande de synthèse.
De la viande élaborée en laboratoire.
La note était plutôt salée : 250000€.
Objectif de ces recherches : sur une planète
qui consomme de plus en plus de viande,
trouver de nouveaux moyens
de produire des protéines animales.
Alors on en est loin.
Et est-ce vraiment souhaitable ?
Il existe d'autres solutions.
Consommer moins ou bien des protéines végétales,
c'est parfois à s'y méprendre.
Restez avec moi,
on va tester tout ça !
En 2019, en Suède, une marque de fast-food bien connue
met au défi ses clients de faire la différence
entre un burger classique à base de viande
et un autre à base de protéines végétales.
En commandant leur menu,
les clients ont une chance sur deux de se voir servir le burger végétal.
À eux de deviner ensuite ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur.
L'expérience rencontre un immense succès
et le résultat est tout simplement incroyable :
44% des clients qui se sont prêtés au jeu
ont été incapables de faire la différence.
Du coup, j'ai décidé de faire le test.
Alors à vue de nez, ces deux steaks se ressemblent beaucoup,
même si j'ai une petite idée !
Ils ont à peu près la même apparence
et la même texture.
Mais lequel contient de la vraie viande ?
La réponse se trouve sous les assiettes.
À moi de deviner !
C'est parti !
Pas mal.
J'ai connu mieux.
Le voisin...
Ça ressemble à de la viande,
mais bon, c'est quand même un peu trop fondant en bouche.
Et puis c'est aussi moins juteux. Non,
je pense que
la viande se trouve ici et le végétal ici.
Verdict :
Yes !
Cela dit, la texture est quand même assez proche de celle de la vraie viande.
Je comprends que l'on puisse confondre.
Ça ressemble, disons, à une viande un peu trop cuite.
Bon, en même temps, il faut comparer ce qui est comparable.
On a comparé deux hamburgers de fast-food,
ça n'a rien à voir avec le steak haché de mon boucher.
Et puis, c'est un steak haché, pas une bavette.
J'aurais pu réaliser la même expérience
avec des nuggets de poulet
et des nuggets sans poulet, c'est à s'y méprendre.
Mais là encore, on compare des nuggets entre eux.
On ne compare pas avec un poulet de Bresse
élevé au grain et en plein air.
Une fois qu'on a dit ça,
comment expliquer cet engouement
pour ces nouveaux produits alimentaires ?
Près de 20% des Français déclarent en avoir déjà consommé au moins une fois.
Si ces nouvelles offres alimentaires
séduisent de plus en plus,
c'est parce que globalement, la viande, on en mange trop.
Ce n'est pas bon pour notre santé ni pour la planète.
Et de plus en plus de consommateurs en sont conscients.
On en consomme en moyenne 85 kilogrammes par personne et par an.
C'est moins qu'avant, mais 85 kilogrammes,
c'est encore trop.
Il a été démontré que la charcuterie
et la viande rouge augmentent les risques de maladies
cardiovasculaires, le diabète de type II et aussi l'apparition de certains cancers.
Le cancer colorectal, par exemple, est plus fréquent
chez les personnes qui consomment
beaucoup de viande rouge.
Pour toutes ces raisons, Santé publique France recommande de limiter
la consommation de viande à 500 grammes par semaine,
ce qui correspond à trois ou quatre steaks par semaine.
En France, l'agriculture est le deuxième poste
d'émission de gaz à effet de serre : 23% du total
et sur toutes les émissions issues de l'agriculture,
les trois quarts proviennent de l'élevage.
Parmi ces gaz, il y a le dioxyde de carbone, mais pas que.
L'agriculture produit aussi du méthane et du protoxyde d'azote.
Le méthane est produit par les ruminants,
les vaches et les moutons dans leur système digestif.
Il est essentiellement rejeté par la bouche
quand ils éructent.
Quand ils rotent, si vous préférez !
Le protoxyde d'azote, lui, est lié à la fabrication
et l'utilisation d'engrais pour la production de fourrage
et à l'épandage des fumiers et des lisiers.
Le pouvoir de réchauffement global du protoxyde d'azote
et du méthane sont respectivement 265 fois
et 28 fois plus importants que celui du CO2.
Heureusement, ils disparaissent plus vite
que le dioxyde de carbone.
Bien sûr, toutes les viandes ne polluent pas de la même manière.
Deux émettent plus de gaz à effet de serre que les autres.
Il s'agit du bœuf et de l'agneau.
La production d'un kilogramme de viande de bœuf émet
27 kilogrammes de gaz à effet de serre.
La même quantité de viande d'agneau, 39 kilogrammes.
Voici de la viande rouge.
Cette couleur, typique de la viande de bœuf, est due
à une protéine : la myoglobine.
Elle est présente dans la fibre musculaire.
C'est elle qui stocke l'oxygène à l'intérieur du muscle
pour le relâcher lors d'un effort physique.
Dans un steak végétal, elle est remplacée
par des colorants naturels
et de l'extrait de betterave ou de la poudre de grenade.
Mais pour reproduire le goût
et la texture de la viande, c'est une autre paire de manches !
Et pour cause.
D'un côté, on a du muscle, autrement dit des protéines animales.
De l'autre, des protéines végétales issues de légumes et de légumineuses :
du riz, des fèves, des pois chiches, des lentilles
et même parfois des haricots.
Alors, on est d'accord, à la base,
aucun de ces produits n'a le goût de viande.
Et pourtant, les fabricants de steaks végétaux
ont surmonté cet obstacle
en ajoutant un extrait de plante : la léghémoglobine.
Il s'agit d'une protéine extraite du soja
qui contient une molécule appelée l'hème.
Non seulement cette molécule donne à la léghémoglobine
un aspect rouge vif car elle contient du fer
qui est à l'origine de la couleur du sang,
mais elle lui donne aussi une odeur
et une saveur proches de celles de la viande de bœuf.
Pour la texture, en revanche, c'est un peu plus compliqué.
Ce sont les fibres musculaires de la viande qui la rendent souple.
Et pour l'instant, on n'arrive pas à trouver de fibres végétales
aussi souples que celles de la viande.
Elles sont plus rigides et donnent au steak végétal un aspect
légèrement friable, parfois un peu pâteux.
Soyons francs, c'est le point faible de ce produit alimentaire.
Mais contrairement à ce que l'on pense,
ils sont aussi riches en protéines.
100 grammes de soja contiennent 36 grammes de protéines végétales,
contre 26 grammes de protéines animales pour 100 grammes de bœuf.
C'est également une bonne source de fibres.
La viande, elle, en est dépourvue.
Or, elles sont excellentes pour le bon fonctionnement de l'intestin.
L'autre alternative pour remplacer la viande issue de l'élevage,
c'est la viande de synthèse, de la viande fabriquée en laboratoire.
On dit aussi la viande in vitro.
Alors j'aurais bien aimé vous en apporter et même la goûter devant vous,
mais on n'en trouve pas encore en Europe.
Pour produire de la viande de synthèse, il faut un poulet
ou une vache en fonction de ce que l'on veut obtenir.
Et aussi une petite boîte comme celle-ci, une boîte de Pétri.
On s'en sert dans les laboratoires pour cultiver
toutes sortes de micro-organismes :
des bactéries, des champignons ou des cellules.
En l'occurrence, on va y placer des cellules souches
prélevées, par exemple, sur du tissu
musculaire de vache adulte.
Ces cellules, qui ne sont pas encore différenciées,
ont la capacité étonnante de se transformer
en différents types de cellules : neurones, globules rouges
ou cellules musculaires pour produire de la viande.
Tout dépend de la solution dans laquelle
baignent les cellules.
Le fameux burger à 250000€, dont nous avons parlé
tout à l'heure, a été conçu de cette manière,
dans une petite boîte de Pétri.
Il était composé de 20000 fibres musculaires produites
à partir de quelques cellules souches.
Plus incroyable, sur le même principe,
une start-up australienne a réussi à créer cette année
une boulette de viande à partir, de protéines de mammouth !
Alors, a priori, comme ça, sur le papier,
la viande in vitro présente pas mal d'avantages.
N'étant pas issue de l'élevage, elle permettrait de
réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de serre,
nécessiterait jusqu'à 95% d'eau en moins.
Sans oublier que ce serait une manière d'obtenir de la viande sans avoir à abattre des animaux.
Pour toutes ces raisons, on la surnomme
"clean meat", viande propre.
Sauf qu'une étude récente, réalisée par l'Université de Californie et publiée par la revue New Scientist,
montre que l'empreinte carbone de la viande artificielle
pourrait être beaucoup plus élevée que celle
de la viande de bœuf.
Cette viande in vitro est composée de nutriments
qui doivent être purifiés.
Or, le processus de purification destiné à éliminer
des toxines contenues dans certaines bactéries est très polluant.
Chaque kilogramme de viande de synthèse pourrait engendrer 4 à 25 fois
plus d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre
que la viande de bœuf classique.
Alors, que faut-il conclure de tout cela ?
Que l'on mange trop de viande ?
Assurément.
Mais comment réduire ?
Certains ont choisi de renoncer à la viande pour la planète,
le bien-être animal.
Mais attention !
Adopter un régime sans viande, ça ne s'improvise pas.
La viande apporte de la vitamine B12, par exemple,
qui contribue à la formation des globules rouges
et qu'on ne trouve dans aucun aliment végétal.
Certains nutriments ne sont pas présents dans les légumes
ou les légumineuses,
ou alors ils résultent d'associations minutieuses.
Donc, il est fortement conseillé de consulter
un médecin nutritionniste avant de s'engager
dans une telle aventure,
surtout si on s'y lance avec des enfants ou des ados en pleine croissance.
Attention aussi aux personnes fragiles.
L'autre solution, c'est de consommer moins,
mais mieux. On l'a dit,
Santé publique France recommande 500 grammes de viande par semaine.
L'idée, c'est de bien choisir, de contrôler son origine,
de discuter avec son boucher.
En général, il sait où et comment l'animal a été élevé.
C'est valable pour toutes les viandes, du bœuf à la volaille
en passant par le porc et l'agneau.
Et puis, pour remplacer la viande
que l'on a retirée de certains menus,
et bien il y a des protéines végétales qui peuvent se présenter
sous la forme de steaks, de crêpes ou de nuggets.
Essayez, mais n'attendez pas forcément de ces plats
qu'ils se rapprochent de la viande classique
en termes de goût et de texture.
C'est une alimentation différente qui propose d'autres saveurs.
Et d'ailleurs, là aussi, il y a à boire et à manger.
Les substituts de viande n'affichent pas tous la même qualité.
Il s'agit souvent d'aliments transformés.
On y trouve de l'huile, du sucre, du sirop de glucose
et de nombreux additifs :
émulsifiants, stabilisants et conservateurs.
Voilà, je vous laisse digérer toutes ces infos.
Si ça a du mal à passer, n'hésitez pas à revoir cette vidéo.
Excellente semaine à toutes et à tous et à très vite
pour une nouvelle vidéo épicurieuse !